FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome.
Welcome to today's talk.
I'm Rachel Amara.
I'm actually based in
our San Francisco office,
but I like to have good excuses
to come down to Mountain View
every now and then
and host authors
here or in San Francisco.
So today I'm really excited to
host Jonathan Robinson, whose
joining us here from
the world of the Bay
Area in northern California.
Jonathan is here to talk
today about his book
"Find Happiness
Now," and he's got
a great hour planned for
us, which includes things
like music and sound effects
and magic tricks and all kinds
of tips on what we
really need and need
to find to be happy now.
So just a quick
update on Jonathan--
so Jonathan's written
over 10 books.
So he is only talking
about, really, one here,
but there's another book here
called "Life's Big Questions"
that some of you have
gotten, and there
is additional books
in his repertoire.
They've been translated in
over 47 languages total,
and he has been-- over 250
million people have reached
and have been
through the programs,
whether he's been
seen on Oprah or CNN
or reading books or things
like this Google Talk.
So please welcome
Jonathan Robinson.
Join me to welcome him.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Thank
you for coming today.
I'm going to begin with
a provocative question,
and that is if you
could download something
on your smartphone, an
app that could stimulate
your brain to feelings
of ecstasy and happiness,
would you plug into
that technology?
How many people would-- yeah?
How many people would not?
And how many people will not
raise their hand no matter
what I ask.
A couple.
Yeah, OK, great.
We may be in a position
where we actually
have to make decisions
like that soon
because the future
technology of happiness
is happening very
quickly, and I'm
going to give you a tour of what
some of those technologies are.
But before I go into
what the future is,
I want to talk about how
to find happiness now,
and all you need is what's
the magical substance
between your own ears, OK?
So we may have
different terms for it,
but I think everything that we
are doing is to be happier now
or in the future,
whether you are trying
to get a lot of money
so you can be happy
or a relationship
so you can be happy.
That is what we're basically
doing all the time.
Now you may have a
different name for it.
You might call it peace of
mind or contentment or life
satisfaction.
But the reason you
came to work today
is because you think
that by doing that,
it's going to make you
happier in the future.
I'll remind you,
if you have kids,
the reason you had kids is
because you think someday they
will help make you happier
in the future, right?
So that's what
we're always doing,
but I have good
news and bad news.
And the bad news is
that we're really not
very good at this skill.
In the last 100 years,
our ability to be happy
has not gone up at all and
yet the level of depression
has risen by a factor of
10 in the last 60 years.
Right now, 10% of Americans
are clinically depressed.
So it's an important
skill to learn
since that's what we're
always trying to do.
Whatever your method is, whether
it be money or relationships
or meditation or
yoga, you're always
trying to get to this
magical state of contentment,
and we really are bad at it.
So there's a lot
room for improvement,
and I think that's good news.
And part of the
good news is knowing
that it is a learnable
skill, but technology
doesn't seem to be helping.
So we have to ask ourselves,
is technology helping us?
We think technology is here
to make our lives better.
And in fact, I am very grateful
to Google and my smartphone
and everything else.
But for a lot of people,
the technology actually
ends up being WMDs-- not
weapons of mass destruction,
but widgets of mass distraction.
The average person watches four
and a half hours of TV a day.
I watch almost none, which
means that some guy in Iowa
has to watch nine hours
to make up for me.
Sometimes I turn on the TV
so that guy can step outside
for a few minutes, you know?
So we have to learn
how to use technology
since we're surrounded
by it to actually boost
our level of happiness
rather than boost
our level of distraction,
and that is a skill as well.
So we are taught in
the American cult-ure--
the American cult-ure-- that
success leads to happiness.
Does Donald Trump look
that happy to you?
If success led to happiness,
he would be a pretty happy guy,
right?
He does not look that happy.
I've met him.
He's not.
But the opposite is true--
happiness does lead to success.
Happy people make $750,000 more
over the course of their life
than unhappy people.
They live nine years longer.
There's no pill you can
take that will help you live
nine years longer, but
happiness actually can do that.
Happy people raise happier kids.
They take fewer sick days.
Corporations pay me to
talk about happiness
because it helps their bottom
line in that people become
more productive.
They also take fewer sick days.
So there's a lot of
benefits to being happy,
and it's not
something that is just
a feel good thing that
makes you more selfish.
In fact, happy people are more
giving than unhappy people.
So it's very important that
people learn this skill
and learn healthy
ways of doing it
so that everybody
benefits from it.
Now the first key in terms
of the skill of happiness
is being able to know what your
target is, having it defined,
because people define
happiness very differently.
For some people, it is a life of
total serenity and relaxation.
For other people, it's total
adrenaline and facing fears
and going for an adventure.
Those are very
different things, so you
want to know what your specific
target is because that will
give you a better chance
of hitting that target.
I learned the importance
of knowing your target
when I was a
freshman in college.
My roommate was one of the
best basketball players in LA,
and he challenged me to
a game of basketball.
We put some money on it.
And I said, I'll play you
a game on one condition--
I can bring out any 1-ounce
gadget onto the court
and place it wherever I want.
He said, OK.
He knew he'd beat me.
So I brought out
this 1-ounce gadget.
Looked a little bit like
this. and I placed it
in a strategic location,
namely over his eyes.
And I said, let the games begin.
Now admittedly, it was
still pretty close,
but I beat one of the best
basketball players in LA
because I knew exactly
what I was aiming for.
The fact that I had
total lack of skill
was not as important as
knowing where the target was.
So you don't want to climb
the ladder success only
to find it's against
the wrong wall.
What is happiness to you?
What does it look like?
Because if you don't define it,
your parents' vision of it will
define it for you or the
American "cult"-ure will define
it for you.
And American culture
says that happiness
equals a lot of money.
But people who are
rich are no happier
than people who are
middle class, so it's
good to define these things.
A second key, which
you probably heard of,
is to practice gratitude.
Now we've all
heard that, but you
need a really good,
simple technique.
So in the '90s, I
interviewed a lot
of well known spiritual
leaders for a book I was doing.
I interviewed everybody from
Mother Teresa-- late Mother
Teresa-- to Dalai
Lama and Deepak Chopra
and Wayne Dyer and
all those people.
And I was asking
them for their best
method for finding
happiness and for finding
a spiritual connection.
And I was amazed
at how many of them
said that gratitude was a key.
So a few years later when I'd
heard of an Indian guru who
supposedly had this magical
mantra for helping people
experience
overwhelming gratitude,
I wanted to know
what that mantra was.
So I travelled 18,000 miles
to India to talk to this guy.
And if you've ever
been to India,
it is not an easy
place to travel to.
And then when I got there, going
on a rickshaw for three hours.
Then I get to the
ashram and I have
to wait in line four
hours to talk to the guru.
Finally I get to him
and I say, guru, gee,
I came all the way from America
to learn your magical mantra
to feel overwhelming gratitude.
Please tell me.
So he says-- his
deep Indian accent--
ah yes, my mantra is the most
powerful mantra on Earth.
Said, normally I don't
say it so quickly,
but you travel all
the way from America.
I will tell you the mantra.
I'm very excited.
And he leans in to
whisper into my ear
and he says, whenever possible,
repeat the following words.
The mantra I give you are
the words "thank you."
I go, that's it?
Thank you?
I travel 18,000 miles
for thank-- that's it?
He says, no, "that's it" is
a mantra you had been using.
That makes you feel like
you never have enough.
My mantra is "thank you,"
not "that's it." "That's it"
will take you nowhere.
Well, I was disappointed
and pretty pissed off,
but I figure I'd traveled so
far I would do what he said,
so I told them thank you.
He said, no, you
can't say thank you.
You have to say thank you from
your heart many times a day
for each of the
life's blessings.
So I tried.
I said thank you,
and I left there.
And I took a taxi, and
as I'm entering the taxi,
I noticed it has
air conditioning.
It's about 105 degrees in India.
I said, oh, well, thank you
for the air conditioning.
And then I leave the taxi and
I put my hand in my pocket.
I have money.
Thank you for my money.
Then I go to the hotel room, and
there's a bottle of clean water
there.
Thank you for the clean water.
And then there's a
nice toilet there.
In India, good toilets
can be hard to find.
Thank you for the toilet.
And then there was air
conditioning in the room
and there was a shower.
I took a shower.
Thank you for the shower.
And in this hotel, there
was actually Wi-Fi in India.
I was very thankful for that.
Get on the computer, Google.
Thank you for Google.
Oh, I feel that
many times a day.
And then on and on it went.
And within about an hour, I had
tears of gratitude going down
my face because we live
better than billionaires
lived 20 years ago.
We have access to all
the world's information
in our phone.
We can talk to anyone in
the world from anywhere
in the world.
We-- for god's sakes, we have
Ben and Jerry's and Haagen Dazs
ice cream never more
than two miles away.
Life is good, right?
But if you don't
have a simple method
for feeling that gratitude,
it all goes by unnoticed.
I mean, how many days
do we do that that we
have all these blessings
and they're invisible to us?
So a simple method
like saying thank you
from your heart for the
people in your life--
even the people that
cause you trouble.
If it weren't for
jerks like you,
I wouldn't know compassion.
Thank you.
So a simple method like that can
help you tune into gratitude.
And we're all so busy
nowadays that it's
nice to have methods that
don't require any extra time.
You're already taking a shower.
You're already eating
Haagen Dazs ice cream.
You're already eating free food.
It just takes a moment
to feel those blessings.
So that's a second key.
A third key is to learn
easy ways to be happy.
A lot of people in my parents'
generation, their method
for being happy was
to work for 40 years,
get the kids out of
the house, retire,
and then they could have
a moment of happiness.
Well, I'm not going
to wait that long.
I can barely wait a
minute and a half.
So we have to find ways that you
can do in under a minute that
help you to feel really good.
My question is, does it pass
the beer and remote test?
People are watching four and
a half hours of TV a day.
Why?
Because all you have to
do is move your thumb
a quarter of an inch and
you get 500 channels.
That's pretty good, right?
Sometimes I don't want to move
my thumb a quarter of an inch,
but I'm willing to
to work that hard.
Or a beer-- immediately
feeling good,
tastes good, and
alters how you feel.
So we need methods
or technologies
for feeling good
that are that simple.
And I have kind of
specialized in my book,
"Find Happiness Now," I talk
about 50 of those methods
because different people
need different methods.
Different strokes
for different folks.
I personally am a
Haagen Dazs person.
Other people are
Ben and Jerry's.
Everybody has different
tastes, so you
have to find what works for you.
So for me, I found that
very simple method--
say, for example, like singing.
It's hard to sing "Twist
and Shout" by the Beatles
and feel bad.
Try it some time.
Or acts of kindness.
Acts of kindness are one of the
quickest and most powerful ways
to boost your own
level of happiness.
Now people don't always
remember my lecture,
but they always remember
my magic tricks.
So I'm going to do
some magic tricks.
Hopefully, you'll get the
metaphor or analogy here.
When we're born, let this
rope represent the wholeness
we have as a child.
The problem is as
we get older, we
can get cut off from
that sense of wholeness
and that sense of
joy that we once had.
See if I can cut through
this-- there we go.
And soon, we're left feeling
cut off from ourselves--
the life's daily stresses.
Well, when that
happens, you have
to find a very
simple method that
will tie those
different parts of you
together so you can
feel whole again.
Now it feels like
a method at first,
but with repetition,
something magical happens.
And what happens-- I'll use my
magic wand here-- what happens
is suddenly you feel restored to
that wholeness and completeness
and joy that you had as a child.
AUDIENCE: Very good.
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
Well, thank you.
You can applaud if you want.
I'm OK with that.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
So in a moment,
I'm going to guide you on what
I call a two-minute meditation.
And in this meditation, I hope
to reduce your stress hormone
levels a cortisol for
the next five hours.
According to the
Institute of HeartMath,
that is the power of this
next two-minute meditation.
I also hope to help you discover
a way that you can be happier
by you accessing your own
internal guidance, OK?
So that's a lot to
do in two minutes,
but I like to work quick so
hopefully that will work.
Now to do this, one of the
things that you'll be doing
is focusing on a
person or animal
that you have great
affection for.
This is my cute puppy, Sophie.
She's adorable.
Although I love
my wife very much,
I often focus on
Sophie because I
have no baggage at
all with Sophie.
But I want you to focus on a
person or animal or young child
that you have great
affection for.
And right now, where you
are, you can close your eyes,
get comfortable.
This won't take very long.
I'll play some background music.
And we'll have you do a
guided meditation in which I
will guide you the whole way.
So close your eyes,
become relaxed.
And think of a person
or child or animal
that you have great
affection for.
And imagine them giving
you a look that reminds you
how much you care about them.
If you can, remember special
times you had with this being.
And if you can, just
think of how glad you are
and how appreciative
you are that they're
a part of your life.
You can imagine holding
them or hugging them
if that helps you to
feel closer to them.
And just think of
how lucky you are
and how grateful you are that
this being is part of your life
and how much you
really appreciate them.
And you can even tell
them inside your head
and see how happy
that makes them.
And breathe in that feeling
of care and gratitude
as best you can.
And from this place
of a quieter mind,
I'm going to ask you a question.
And just listen for any
answer that might feel right.
And the question is,
what do you need to know
or what do you need to do to
be even happier in your life?
What do you need
to know or what do
you need to do to be even
happier in your life?
Take a few moments
to think about that.
What else can you do to
be happier in your life?
And when you're ready, you
can come back to the room.
Slowly come back.
That took about two minutes.
Looks like some you
went out and smoked
a joint during that time.
You have that red-eye
look a little bit.
That's the power of two
minutes where you're actually
affecting your blood
chemistry radically
for the next few hours through
a simple method like that.
And if we asked ourselves
what I call power questions--
questions that help us get
in touch with what we need
to know, like what do you
need to know to be happier
or who do I love
and who loves me.
These are simple ways to guide
our mind in a helpful way
because the mind--
the human mind
is like Velcro for
negativity and we
need it to be more like Teflon.
So these simple methods,
and many others in my book
or that you can get
online or anywhere,
can teach you how to access
the joy and happiness
that we had a lot as kids.
I know a group of people who
are really happy almost all
the time.
Unfortunately, most of them
are under the age of five.
So we don't have to learn
how to be happy so much
as to let go of our negative
habits of holding on to worries
and problems and
things like that.
A fifth key to being
happy is the ability
to invest in relationships.
The number one correlation
to human happiness
is the quality and quantity
of your relationships.
Not only that, the ability
to be kind, the ability
to connect with people.
In fact, I'll give
you an opportunity
now to be kind if you want.
I'm looking for
somebody who would
be willing to give me $5
or $10 on the condition
that you will not
be getting it back.
Anybody at all?
Anybody who's kind?
Just if you have $5
or $10 and you're
willing going to give it
to me, just take it out
and I will collect it.
A guy has to make
a living, you know?
This man here looks
like he has something.
Oh, OK.
Great.
Oh, thank you.
He beat you to it.
Thank you for that.
AUDIENCE: [GROANING]
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
Yeah, well, I find
that people who are willing to
be the first to give themselves
usually get back a lot
more than they give.
In fact, what I have
found is that people
who are willing to
take that risk usually
do rather well in life.
In this case, they get
back 10 times the amount.
And you may keep that for being
willing to take that risk.
Let's give this man a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Usually I get
a better response a second time
I ask for money.
I don't know why that is.
Really, we are hesitant to take
that initial emotional risk,
but people who are willing to
do that make those connections.
Intimacy is one of
the keys to happiness,
but we're not
taught how to do it.
Luckily, the instructions are
in the word-- in-to-me-see.
Vulnerability and
human kindness are
one of the most sought
after things in the world
today because the
world is so mechanized,
and we're all so busy that
moments of real kindness
and intimacy we all crave.
So being able to invest
in your friendships.
And you know, 300 Facebook
friends does not equal one
really good friend,
nor does a world
of infinite and free
pornography substitute
for intimate or
sexual satisfaction.
And we have a nasty
habit of using technology
to think that we are connecting
with people when, really, we're
just getting the superficial
on the surface level
and not getting the real meat
or heart of what we're after.
And that's why I
say that you have
to be careful of widgets
of mass distraction.
A sixth key to
finding happiness is
being willing to
face your fears.
As you get older,
it's really easy
to get lost in security
and a groove and a rut.
And the only difference
between a groove and a grave
is a couple of feet, so you
have to be careful about that.
And being willing to face
your fears of embarrassment,
failure, rejection.
And this is hard, but
that is one of the keys
to help make you a
more expanded person.
Now I was really a
shy person as a kid.
I was so shy that by
the time I was 17,
I never actually had asked
a woman out on a date.
But it is possible to learn to
overcome your fears relatively
quickly.
So what I did was
I said, I'm going
to get rejected by 10 women
in one day, and if I do that,
I will treat myself
to a trip to Hawaii.
So I went to the
university bookstore
and I go up to a woman.
And I'm literally drenched
in sweat-- beads of sweat
dripping down my face.
I'm shaking, and I go up to
a woman, and I go, hello.
This poor girl, she
looks at me and she says,
are you all right?
Do you need an ambulance?
She thought I was having
some kind of seizure.
I said, no, don't
call an ambulance.
So obviously, an awkward
conversation ensued,
and I asked her out and she
said, no, I have a boyfriend,
but thank you for asking.
I really appreciate that.
Are sure you're OK?
Yeah.
One down, nine more to go.
And when you face your fears,
it gets easier and easier
with each person.
So by the fourth woman,
I'm feeling like, wow, I'm
breaking through
a lifelong fear.
This feels great.
I could do this
every Friday night.
So I'm going through this,
but the seventh woman
ruined my momentum.
By now, I kind of had a
script, I knew how it would go.
So I say, hey, I'm new here.
I haven't met many people.
You look very nice.
Would you be interested
in going out some time?
And she said, sure.
It was at that moment I realized
I had no script for "sure."
So I said, sure what?
She said, I'd love
to go out with you.
Really?
OK.
I wrote down her number.
Great.
Now I feel really happy.
And when you are
happy, it kind of
is like a magnet towards you.
So the next woman said
yes, and the next,
and the next, and the next,
and the next.
I had eight straight dates.
Now I had a new problem.
I needed three more rejections
or I couldn't go to Hawaii.
So I figured I'd start
acting like a jerk.
So I go up to a woman,
I go hey sugar lips.
What do you say you come
to my place Friday night.
I'll show you a
really good time.
What do you say, honey?
She looks at me not unlike
you're looking at me right now.
Then she says, sure.
[LAUGHTER]
JONATHAN ROBINSON: She figured
anybody that weird or funny
she wanted to get to know.
So that didn't work.
But I threw on some water.
I did my shaking routine.
I got my three final rejections.
I went to Hawaii,
but most important, I
learned that facing your
fear is a learnable skill
and that you can overcome
lifelong fears in an hour.
People ask me, how did I meet
Mother Teresa, the Dalai Lama,
Deepak Chopra, all these people?
I said, well, when I have 17,
I faced my fear of rejection.
I took it from a 10
to a 5 in one hour,
and that changed my life.
So being willing to
do that is really key.
Fear of embarrassment,
fear of failure,
fear of rejection--
the big three.
Just out of curiosity--
probably a lot you
saw the movie "The Matrix"
in which Neo is asked,
do you want a red pill,
which involves seeing
the truth about yourself
and facing fear;
or do you want the
blue pill, which
involves being lulled to sleep,
believing whatever you want?
Just out of a show of
hands, how many of you
Googlers would say
that, given that choice,
that you would have
chosen the red pill?
Raise your hand if
you're in that category.
OK, good.
Now many think you would
have taken the blue bill?
None?
Wow.
That's impressive.
Must be a pretty fearless group.
That's good to know.
OK.
It's important to know that
because that decision--
whether you're a red or a
blue pill taker-- really
determines the course of your
life to a very large extent.
Seventh key to knowing
how to be happy
is to know your inner obstacles.
As Socrates said, know thyself.
And that involves knowing
what's in the way of you
being happier.
Now I have a very--
I'm a psychotherapist,
and I'm very good at pinpointing
for people their biggest
obstacle in the way
of them being happier.
And I'll show you how I do this.
What I need is a volunteer
willing to come up and work
with me.
Raise your hand if you're
willing to volunteer.
OK, great.
Hold on just one second.
I think something
is very interesting,
and that is about a minute
ago, everybody in this room
was a red pill taker.
And then when I
say, would you like
to take a red pill now and
know the truth of yourself
as something that's in the
way have you being happier,
there was only one
red pill taker.
Isn't that interesting?
You may not be as
dedicated to the red pill
as you think because
when I asked, would you
like to face a small amount
of potential embarrassment
to know a valuable truth about
yourself, 98% of you said,
yeah, but not now.
So one obstacle that you
might have to being happier
is that you have an ability
to say some story in your head
as to why now is not a good
time to take a red pill.
And that gets in the
way of us being happier.
So just think back, what
did you say to yourself
so that you didn't
have to come up here?
This gentleman here
didn't have the same story
or excuse that you did.
And since he didn't,
he gets a free book.
Let's give them a
hand for being brave.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
Really, now I'm
an easily fearful
person as well.
I don't like being
embarrassed, but I
am aware of the story in my
head that I always come up
with for why now is not the
time to take the red pill.
And sometimes--
not all the time--
but sometimes, I
transcend that story.
But first you have to
know what that story is,
and you have to know that we're
always given an opportunity
to take the red
pill or a blue pill.
It's not one choice you make.
It's a choice you
make 100 times a day.
Whether or not to say
hello to the person,
whether or not to say what
you're really thinking
about them, whether or
not to say what you want.
Those are little
red pill moments.
And the more that
you take it, the more
expanded your life
is likely to be.
An eighth key for being happy
is to master the meaning
that your mind creates.
I mentioned before that
our minds are always
creating a sense of
Velcro for negativity,
and we want to make
it more like Teflon.
How do you do that
in the midst of life?
You get in a car accident, you
think, oh, this is horrible.
Well, we need to be
able in that moment
to change the meaning
we create for things
so that we don't feel bad
for a long period of time.
I'm reminded of a
story-- a businessman who
once came to counseling for
me, he shared this story.
And he was kind of an
arrogant, rich guy,
and he said he was in
Thailand traveling.
He went up to a monk
and he said to the monk,
well, if you're so
wise, why don't you
teach me a lesson
about Heaven and Hell?
So this monk looks
up at him and says,
teach you about Heaven and Hell?
I couldn't teach you anything.
You are like an arrogant man.
You don't have a caring
bone in your body.
You even smell bad.
You probably eat meat.
You just don't care
about anything.
Just get out of my sight
and stop wasting my time.
Well, the man gets
red in the face.
He shakes with rage.
He gets ready to punch
this monk in the face.
And an instant before
he throws the punch,
the monk says, that's Hell.
Well, the man was
just overwhelmed
that this monk risking
beaten up to teach him
this lesson about Hell.
He unclinched his fist, and
then he bowed to the monk.
And the monk said,
and that's Heaven.
What I like about that
story is that we're always
creating our own moments
of Heaven and Hell
by how we interpret things.
He interpreted the
first words-- I'm
be insulted for no good reason--
created a moment of Hell.
He took the same
words a moment later
and said that this person just
taught me a valuable lesson
and created a
moment of gratitude.
So how to do this
in a simple way?
Well, there's one
question I use,
and the question is what
could be good about this?
What could potentially
be good about this?
I mean, taking on
something big, like, again,
to a fender bender.
You don't think what could
be good about this normally,
but hey, maybe I'll
meet this person.
Maybe I was destined-- I met
my wife in a fender bender.
That was useful.
You could see focus
on, well, I might
have been in a worse
accident later.
I might have been killed later.
Now I'm not going to because
I'm in a little fender bender.
Or who knows what
you might think of.
Maybe this will help me to
become a more careful driver.
Whatever it is, we're
always making up the future.
We don't know.
You might as well make
it up so it's empowering,
and a simple question like
that can help do that.
This is me doing magic
for Syrian refugees
a couple months ago.
These are kids who
have lost parents,
lost limbs, and
certainly lost a country.
But in a moment of play and
humor, everybody is smiles.
That's a power of
play and humor.
And that's a skill.
It's not a skill
we have to learn.
Every three-year-old is playful.
Average four-year-old
laughs 100 times a day.
The average 12-year-old, twice.
So being able to
enjoy play and humor.
And we don't even
play tennis as adults.
We compete at tennis.
We compete at everything.
But play and humor is a tonic
that makes all of life better.
And to create an analogy that
might help you remember this,
I'm going to do one
last magic trick.
Could you throw this to any
random person in the audience?
Just to-- oh, great.
Yeah.
OK, well, what I
want you to do is
I want you to think of a
number between 1 and 1,000.
Don't tell me what it is.
And I'm going to write down
what you're going to say.
OK?
Now this really is
a random person.
I want you to know that.
I think I got it.
OK.
I'm always a little nervous
when it comes to this.
I'm want you to speak up really
loud so everybody can hear you.
I'm going to ask you a question.
Is the number 237?
Yes or no.
AUDIENCE: No.
JONATHAN ROBINSON: I wrote
down what he was going to say.
Pretty good, huh?
You are not impressed evidently.
I can't tell you how
I do that secret,
but what I can tell you
is it does have a point,
and the point is I
try to set up life
so I have a very good
chance of succeeding.
When you bring play and
humor into your life,
you have a very good
chance of succeeding
at the game of happiness.
So that's something you
might want to invest in.
And last but not
least, tenth key
before we go into the future
is if you want to be happy,
you want to learn how
to dive into the now.
Being here now is the
greatest key to happiness.
And most people think that
they're already in the now,
but mostly we're thinking
of problems and plans
and relationships in
our chatterbox mind,
and we never learn
how to let go of that.
So we need to learn how to let
go of that and be here now.
And be here now.
Now you may be
wondering how many times
I'm going to say that.
That's part of being
here now, being
with what your thoughts
are saying about now.
Being OK with silence is an
important part of being here
now, one that we're not
very good at in this age
where we can always
have something going on.
Learning how to relax
and, beyond the turmoil
of our minds, finding the deeper
ocean where peace actually
always is is part
of being here now.
And that's a skill
that is learnable.
Now we talked about
being happy in the now.
I want to now take
you on a tour of what
is likely to happen towards
happiness in the future.
And one thing to know
is that the stakes
are big because if
we do this wrong,
we could end up like rats
pressing that bar in a cage,
stimulating ourselves
to have instant pleasure
while everything
else in life goes by.
Rats will actually die
pressing a pleasure button that
is stimulating the pleasure
center of their brain
because it's so powerful.
Well, it's not long before
we are able to do that,
and we want to make sure
that we don't sacrifice
all the depth of life for
just instinct gratification.
And there's certainly
billions if not trillions
of dollars at stake
for people who
learn how to help
people feel happy
since that is what
we're ultimately after.
Now there's five new
technologies or approaches
to finding happiness I
want to briefly touch upon,
and one of them--
the first one--
is what I call sensory
and reality simulators.
And these are already
happening to some extent.
The Oculus Rift VR.
Soon there's going to be
full body suits that people
can wear for virtual reality.
There's other things
like video games.
Young people spend a huge
portion of their lives
watching video games now.
Is that a good thing?
I don't know.
We're doing an
experiment on humanity
though in which a
large part of humanity
is spending most of their free
time either watching TV, being
on the internet, or
doing video games.
And these will get much, much
better in the next few years,
Much more addictive.
And if you've ever read the
book "Reality Is Broken,"
I think there's good
sides and bad sides
to be made to this argument.
But it will be
happening, and it will
impact how people
find happiness.
A second key-- this is even
a little bit more scary.
These are what I
call brain enhancers.
These are things like Direct
Brain Stimulation, or DBS.
Or happy pills.
If you saw the movie
"Limitless" or "Lucy,"
Big Pharma is spending billions
to find pills that make people
happy, more alert,
more productive.
They've we've done some good
ones now in clinical trials
and they're going to get better.
Things like EEG.
Right here, this
came out last month.
This is a four-channel mobile
EEG that you wear like this.
It comes out on your
smartphone and it gives you
an audio signal
or a visual signal
as to whether you're moving
towards peace of mind or not.
$300, came out last month.
It's called the Muse.
Those are going to
get better and better.
Then there's things like
transcranial magnetic
stimulation-- how to stimulate
the brain magnetically
to get to the pleasure
centers of the brain.
Or DBS-- put an electrode
in the brain right
into the pleasure center.
They do this for severely
depressed people right now.
Works extremely well.
Right now, the people do not
have control of their own brain
pacemaker because
they found that they
were hitting that
button way too often.
Do you think somebody's
going to figure out
how to get control of
that brain pacemaker?
I bet they will.
So these are some
things that are
going to affect human beings
and will be available soon.
Third key, or third technology,
is social robots and AI.
If you saw the movie
"Her," you know
that it looks like
pretty good to fall
in love with your
operating system.
That technology is probably
12 to 15 years away.
There is a technology
now called Roxxxy
the Sex Robot, which sounds
really gross, doesn't it?
And so I talked to a guy who
owned a Roxxxy the Sex Robot.
And this had a big
yuck factor for me.
But as you talked, I'm going,
well, that sounds reasonable.
And he said something
like, well, Roxxxy's
always available.
And then he said, best
sex I've ever had.
Really?
And I said, how much is she?
And he said, about
$3,000-- or as he put it,
a lot less than
my first marriage.
Now I didn't buy
one of these-- yet--
but you can see that as this
technology-- oh, and Roxxxy
talks.
You can have a conversation
with her, kind of like Siri.
But that conversation is
going to get better over time.
And you can see that
people-- in Japan,
these robots are
becoming more widespread,
that these technologies of
actually having relationships
with robots is
not that far away.
And it's better that we
decide now what kind of person
we want to be because
technology has
a way of creeping up on this.
The average person now looks
at their smartphone 110 times
today, but if you take
down the bottom 10%,
it's actually 190 times a day.
20 years ago, we
wouldn't have said,
yes, I'm going to be interrupted
every three minutes in my life
by something on a screen, yet
now we don't even notice it.
It's accepted.
So these technologies are
getting better and better,
and we have to decide is this
a good thing or not for us.
According to Google's
own Ray Kurzweil,
"By 2030, technology will
enable us to process thoughts
millions of times
faster than today.
With faster thinking,
we can develop an idea
or face a situation
and immediately
run thousands of what-if
simulations in our mind,
ensuring a correct
decision always.
This ability to
never make mistakes
will enhance our peace
of mind and happiness."
Basically, we will have
artificial intelligence coaches
that will help guide us
towards better happiness.
Well, we're not that good at
it, so maybe that's a good idea.
Maybe not.
Maybe it'll make us happier.
Maybe it'll make
us more infantile.
I don't know.
But I thought I would show you
what such a thing might look
like in a Google search
of the near-term future.
And here's my version of that.
Hello, Google.
Wait, let me get this a
little bit louder here.
Hi Google.
COMPUTER: Hello.
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
I'm wondering,
what can I do to be happier?
COMPUTER: What KIND of happiness
are you looking for, Jonathan?
Are you looking for
a good time tonight?
More peace of mind?
More play?
Or perhaps a
romantic connection?
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
I think I'm looking
for a woman who would
a good match for me,
enjoy sports like I do?
COMPUTER: Based on what I know
about your taste in women,
within a 10 mile radius,
I found seven women
who match your personality
type and enjoy sports.
They all could be a very
good match as for you.
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Well,
that sounds interesting.
COMPUTER: Here's a picture
of my favorite match for you.
Her name is Kirsten.
She's a therapist like you,
and she loves football.
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Well, can
you send me more information?
COMPUTER: Already in your inbox.
By the way, she loves roses, so
if you go on a date with her,
make sure you bring
a dozen roses.
That'll make a great
first impression.
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
Well, thanks, Google.
COMPUTER: Anything else I
can do for you, sweetie?
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
Yeah, do you think
this shirt goes with
this sport jacket?
COMPUTER: Absolutely.
You're looking hot.
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Well, thanks.
I'll talk to you later.
COMPUTER: I look forward to it.
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Now
won't that be great?
So what are you guys doing here?
Get to work.
Come on.
I hope it'll be great.
I don't really know.
But those types of
things will influence
how we pursue happiness
in the future.
And people are going to
want technologies like that
because, as I said,
most people are pretty
bad at learning how to be happy.
A fourth key or
technology is what
I call high vibration emitters.
These are devices, kind of like
this one-- this device actually
emits vibrations that make
people feel high and good.
I brought my friend over
here, Dr Norman McVeigh,
who invents devices like this.
Raise your hand, Norman.
And he has invented
machines where
he can get a whole room to
get stoned at the same time
without having to
smoke anything.
This technology is
getting better as
with other technologies.
And soon, people are going to
want to have access to that.
This man with the
afro down here,
Sai Baba, he was
a guru in India.
He's gone now.
But he could emit a
vibration that if I
was within a mile of him, I
would feel a state of bliss.
Now when we are
able to figure out
what vibration that
person is putting off
and can duplicate
it, that's going
to be a very popular technology.
I can tell you that.
Now a question we
have to ask ourselves
is, have the
machines already won?
10% of people are looking at
their smartphone during sex.
We consume over seven
hours of media a day.
That's a lot of time.
That's average.
We check our phones an average
of 110 times a day-- a lot more
for many people.
And we have to
know, is this adding
to the depth and
quality of our life?
In some cases, yes.
And in some cases,
it's an avoidance.
We do it to avoid
pain, and using
technology or any
distracted device
to get us away
from our humanness
and from being here now I
don't think is a good thing.
Will we have the ability to
discern between those two?
Right now, we're not
doing such a good job.
But these are important
topics to talk about
because we all want
a life of depth.
We all want the juice of life.
And that, in some ways, is
becoming harder and harder
as these technologies progress.
So our happiness
challenge-- actually, I
want to go into one more.
I think I missed it here.
I want to talk about
one more thing before I
go into a happiness
challenge, and that
is that spiritual and
psychological goal
technologies are
also progressing,
that we are learning
how to develop and help
people towards peace of mind.
It used to be you were
a Christian or a Jew,
you were born that way,
you stayed that way.
But what if you could take
a personality test that
could say, this is going to
help you the most spiritually,
or this is going to help you
the most psychologically.
Technologies like
neurolinguistic programming
or EMDR or EFT-- they all go
by these very long initials--
these are developing
technologies
that, as a therapist, I know can
help people pass trauma, help
them to feel good
relatively quickly
without months of talk therapy.
Same with spiritual
methods-- different types
of meditations, different
types of techniques
for different types of folks.
The integral of meditation
movement, integral spirituality
led by Ken Wilber-- all
different ways to help people
know exactly what will help
with their shortcomings
so that they can progress
as quickly as possible.
Now part of our
happiness challenge
is to pursue connection and
meaning, not just pleasure;
to be able to keep
our social bonds
alive despite distraction.
You can use Skype to
connect with people
you wouldn't normally
connect with.
That's important.
To be able to question
if new gadgets are really
making us happier.
Now I must admit to you
that I am an addict.
I love gadgets.
Now when I saw that people were
looking at their smartphone
during sex and having
sex with robots,
I started to feel
a little superior.
Oh, I don't do that.
And then my wife
suggested I do a two day
fast from anything
with a screen.
It was not pretty.
I'm like sneaking
looks at my smartphone
while she's talking
to me or something.
It was very humbling
and very difficult,
but ultimately very satisfying.
Now obviously, we need to
balance all these things
if we want to be happy, because
happiness does require balance.
But having that as part
of the conversation
is important because the
whole culture is moving
towards bigger, faster, more
and bigger, faster, more
is not always what
leads to happiness.
In a little bit, I'm
going to end with a story.
If you want to
find more about me,
I have a website,
FindingHappiness.
It has a lot of free stuff on
it, including happiness tips.
I have the "Find Happiness
Now" book back there.
I have a six CD set
on deeper happiness,
I do coaching seminars,
blah, blah, blah.
You can get cards from
me, whatever it is.
I do want to end with
a story, and then we'll
open up to question and answer.
Many years ago, I went to
see another guru in India.
Looked like this.
Named [? Punjati ?].
And once again, you fly to
India, you're jet lagged.
You're a little disoriented.
The moment I walked into his
ashram, he said, you, sit here.
I go, OK.
So I sit in front of this guy.
And he looks at
me really closely.
He goes right up to me
and he goes, who are you?
Well, I didn't know what
the protocol was, so I said,
I'm Jonathan Robinson
from the United States.
And him and everybody in
the room busted up laughing.
I thought that was
the wrong answer.
And then he had compassion.
He said, no, who are you really?
And I tried different answers--
I'm a husband, I'm an author,
I'm a speaker, whatever it is.
And he kept on saying, no, no,
that's not it, that's not it,
no.
And finally, I ran
out of answers,
and I just looked in
his eyes, and his eyes
were like sparkling diamonds.
I started to feel like I was
falling in love with this guy.
And I felt like that
choice between the red pill
and the blue pill-- do I
close up or do I let go?
In this case, I let go.
And a wave of love just hit me.
And before I knew it,
I was just crying.
I just kept crying.
I couldn't stop crying.
I had never felt so
much love in my life.
And I'm sitting
there practically
drooling in his lap crying.
And as I'm in his lap crying,
he taps me on the head
and he said something
I'll never forget.
He says, this love you're
feeling now is who you are.
This joy you're feeling now is
who you are in your essence.
And your job in this world
is to never forget that.
So that has stayed with me,
and I echo his words to you.
Love is who we are, and your
job is to get in touch with that
because only if you get in
touch with some peace and love
and happiness can
you really give
your best to a world
in desperate need,
and really give your best to
the people you most care about.
Thank you for
listening to me today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Questions?
Anyone have a question?
AUDIENCE: I think
from the presentation
the part that especially
for me resonates the most
or I get more
questions about is when
you talk about what's
happiness for you
or what are your fears and--
JONATHAN ROBINSON:
What are your fears?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and what
is happening is happiness.
And I find that those are kind
of like the biggest questions.
And after many,
many years, I still
don't think that I know what
[INAUDIBLE] answer that.
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Right.
One, with questions,
you don't have
to think so much in
trying to find an answer.
Sometimes the
question is the path.
I have the same questions
I had-- how to find peace?
That's like an ongoing question.
Now I keep on learning as
I explore that question,
but there is no final answer.
There's better
and better answers
that are deeper and deeper.
So keep on exploring a question
that resonates for you.
I'm still focusing on
how can I open my heart.
There's not just
one answer to that.
That is a lifelong question.
It's like a friend, and
it keeps on-- as I ask it,
I keep on getting to deeper and
deeper, more subtle and subtle
levels of that question.
Or how can I know
gratitude more?
Just keep that question
alive in your life.
AUDIENCE: I've kind of been
thinking about happiness
in general for a few
months now, I think.
I got caught in the rat
race for several years
working, and working
toward that end goal, sort
of career development
and all those things.
But I was wondering if-- I think
a lot of times we get caught up
trying to find pure joy
and elation every day.
Do you think some
of the happiness
is just kind of being OK
with whatever it is at home?
All right, so maybe
not this 100% number
you're looking for,
but like, hey, 80%,
I'm pretty good most the time.
There's going to be
some ups and downs.
Do you look at it like that?
Or is there maybe--
JONATHAN ROBINSON: Yeah,
I look at it like that.
And everybody, no matter
how happy they are,
they have good
moments, bad moments.
Every now and then, you'll
find yourself in a good moment.
That happens, right?
Give it some more space.
A lot of times, you're
happy-- the other day,
I was enjoying my dog.
I was petting her, telling
her how much I love her.
And then I thought, oh,
I got stuff to do today.
And I said, what could be
more important than this?
I'm loving this.
My dog's loving it.
I'm just going to sit here
and keep on telling her
how much I love her until I
don't want to do that anymore.
We don't even give our happy,
joyful, intimate moments space.
We're always moving
on to the next thing.
So one way to be happier is
just to take the happy moments
you have and don't go onto
the next thing so quickly.
But yeah, wherever
your life is, you're
going to have ups and downs.
But over time, you learn to
let go of the negative emotions
more quickly.
Think of little kids.
They let go of negative
emotions like that.
They can go from
totally having a tantrum
to fine in two minutes.
Some adults, they have
a problem with somebody,
they don't let go for years.
So you learn to let go of the
negative emotions quickly.
You give the positive
emotions more space.
And soon, you'll
find that you just
feel better a lot
more of the time.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you, Jonathan.
JONATHAN ROBINSON: OK, thank
you very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]